i had conversations with my brother
i always have conversations with my
brother because he's my brother and he's
my best friend
and obviously he was aware of what was
going on
wow if that's how you treat your best
friend i'd hate to be your dog
you know i always welcome those who come
around to my way of thinking
yep it took a few years but people are
starting to embrace replacing milk with
vodka
when eating captain crunch
still tastes good and what was once
considered a conspiracy theory involving
cat's new mysterious husband
is now starting to be accepted as
conventional wisdom
[Laughter]
i mean how do we know they arrested the
right guy
look at it i think the news speaks for
itself it is uncanny but do you know
what else is uncanny
how the activist media only retreats
when their stupid ideas start to cost
them politically
take crime last year as it decimated our
cities
the media mocked it democratic cities
are
in chaos right now is this what you want
from joe biden and they're going to take
your country away and they're taking
down the statues and
crime is rising oh my gosh it's so
bad and again defunding police it's like
yeah indeed but then the light bulb went
off in lemon's otherwise
empty head maybe rolling your eyes over
crime victims
isn't a good look i wonder if he now
thinks it's a blind spot for democrats
i think this is a blind spot for
democrats
i think democrats are ignoring this
problem or hoping that it will go away
and it's not going to go away joe biden
may be afraid to do it
i'm not sure maybe he won't maybe he is
he's got to address it
the writing has to stop chris as you
know
and i know it's showing up in the
polling it's showing up in focus groups
it is the only thing
right now that is sticking
i'd say that's an about face except
they're always talking out of their
asses
that was a while ago but this is the
left the problem is never the crime
it's the effect it has politically or as
ezra klein puts it
how crime hurts the liberal project
liberal project i guess it's like the
lincoln project except you molest
everyone
[Laughter]
allegedly in a tweet thread he says this
violence is spiking homicides were up by
25 to 40 percent in 2020
the largest single year increase since
1960 and 2021
isn't looking any better now remember
this is from a new york times liberal
which is why klein has to add this is a
crisis on its own terms but it's also a
crisis
for the broader liberal project and he's
right
all those dead people make defunding the
police look really bad
but klein knew he couldn't get his side
to care
unless he suggested that not caring
would threaten their political fortunes
they only feel your pain to get elected
he then adds that violent crime causes
families to leave cities businesses to
close
banks refusing loans as property values
drop there are lifelong
impacts that traumatize kids so wait is
he talking about crime
or liberalism now this might be the
point where klein sees the value in
policing
but instead he focuses on political
fallout
like the atlanta mayor isn't running
again after being called soft on crime
he points out
there's a recall effort in san francisco
of district attorney
tesa boudin who so far has banned cash
bail and released felons from jail
both his parents were weather
underground domestic terrorists
i guess the grenade doesn't fall far
from the tree
and now klein worries crime's the top
concern in nyc
behind covid which leads to his key fear
if these numbers keep getting worse then
as with nixon and reagan in the 70s and
80s
it could bring law and order
conservatives including trump
back to power in 2024. so there you go
the reason why you should address crime
it's not about the victims
it's who returns to power he fears that
rising crime could bring back leaders
who care about rising crime he's
literally afraid of safe streets
what else is he afraid of child car
seats and toothpaste with fluoride
klein realizes that as crime rises
citizens don't vote for liberals
so either you fight the crime or you get
more criminals to vote
so what's klein's solution well more
liberal policies apparently
yeah cities destroyed by left-wingers
just need more of them
that's like giving dana another picture
of her dog
but now they see crime victims are less
inclined to sympathize with the liberal
system that lets this mayhem unfold
but instead of empathizing the dems fret
about their power
they say wow we could lose elections
when they should be asking
why is the crime happening but they
can't because the answer is in the
mirror
it's the policies they push so the only
way they can deplore violence is through
its political consequences
as opposed to the looting and the
rioting that cause billions of damages
which is why their idea of eliminating
the crime problem is to eliminate the
stats
just stop arresting shoplifters who
cares if it's so out of control
walgreens has closed
17 of its stores in san francisco alone
who does that hurt not the media or the
rich
no it's the poor the elderly the
minorities in those areas
i wonder what the angry white male has
to say
how does it affect me well i don't go
into the city all that much anymore
i used to like to do that that's a shame
funny thing is
i bet the politicians making these
decisions don't go into the city that
much either
oh well i gotta run afternoon tea time
in my safe gated community
i don't know i think i saw a racist hand
signal in there of course i will accept
any liberal who wants to fight crime
even if it's for the preservation of
their own power
if they think being tough on crime means
they'll win more elections then
act on it my issue is they don't when
they talk tough they don't act tough
later
it's like when i told people i'll fight
them on the playground after school and
then i didn't
show up that was last week i'm telling
you
those eighth graders are getting bigger
but the dems say they're going to solve
crime and then they continue with
policies that led it to spread in the
first place
happily though not all events
are marred by violence national greg
gutfeld day which was
held saturday in manhattan went off
beautifully without
without any problems at all let's take a
look
ladies and gentlemen national greg
gutfeld day starts in three
two one
and what a glorious day it was what
began on the streets of new york city
quickly spilled through towns across the
world
a day that meant so much to so many
greg is already being credited with
boosting global tourism
it's the best time of the year i think
it's the best time for visitors to come
and see our city even former president
donald trump celebrated greg in his own
way
republicans and democrats were seen
making out in the streets
dogs and cats were seen hugging in a
time of great division
greg truly brings us all together
the outpouring of love to greg and each
other
led to the most unexpected conclusion
we had to stop there for fcc reasons
but you see it is possible to unify this
country all it takes is one
very sexy hero
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
she's so sharp she can open a clam shell
with earthbox
the federalist culture editor emily
josinski
he's so smart rubik's cube struggle to
solve him
the battle on b chief executive steph
dylan
those jokes really make you think you
should see another comedian
comedian joe mackey is back
she donated blood and they gave it back
fox news contributor cat tim
[Applause]
go first before i get to the guests i
was really surprised that neither of you
showed up at national greg gutfeldt day
i
i had reserved seating and everything
yeah uh were you invited i'm a little
distraught i'm just
i think i need to talk to my husband
when i get home after the model
where was cats
we may not see her again now that the
news is out all right so let me go to
you seth seth
you're uh you helm the incredibly
successful babylon b
which if you haven't if you don't follow
it on twitter or read it you're crazy
you should
uh you i don't think the babylon b would
be as successful as it is if it wasn't
for
the mentality that drives for example
their their
their thoughts on crime the democrats
thoughts on crime well yeah i mean it's
it's so absurd and look at kamala harris
was uh
raising funds to bail out rioters yes
excuse me peaceful protesters right
right of course in minnesota i mean it
all these instances where you have all
this violent crime rising up in the
streets they're prodding it and
encouraging it
and then to see people turn around and
and act like oh
this this rise in crime is something
that's gonna it's gonna help our
opponents politically
yeah well well then what were you doing
this whole time yes you created this
problem it's not crime that's hurting
leftists it's leftists who are hurting
leftists
exactly emily we know you're a violent
person um
well known yes it's well i've sweet we
were talking about it before the show
questioning whether we should have armed
security here you think he's joking
what um why can't like it's interesting
why can't the political uh
consequences and real life consequences
align themselves what's wrong with that
but it's like but no the dems can only
think about it in a political way
yeah they think about in a political way
and it's just interesting to see
somebody like ezra klein slip back into
the sort of don
draper role and be like listen we can't
sell these democrats while there's
riots happening when in fact actually
they're sort of like
your question about the liberal project
he has a podcast where he asked do
democrats have an answer to violence
the answer is obviously no because we've
let them try
experiment running our cities for
decades their answer is always to
throw more money and apply more
bureaucracy to a situation
instead of actually saying maybe we need
to shrink things here maybe we need to
re-budget maybe we need to do
try these different things instead their
entire world view has calcified into
something that is actually
more tolerant of criminal behavior i
mean i live in washington dc
the tolerance that exists around some
tragic populations like the homeless
population
it's not good for crime rates yeah but
they're going to keep doing it yeah you
know what's interesting it's like the
democrats are
therapists for criminals and then ezra
klein is the therapist
for the democrats to help them get like
so how is it going not well they're
still committing a lot of crime
there's crime all over they go you know
have you really thought about doing more
of this and it's always the same thing
joe
joe are you terrified right now that
what's going on in the cities
i am greg and first off i want to
apologize for not being a great gutfield
day i celebrate privately
it's just it's you have may the fourth
cinco de mayo mother's day
and great gut feel day all in a row it's
a lot i'm still hungover it's a lot you
know what it is it's a lot like
thanksgiving and christmas when they and
then new year's eve where they kind of
all pile up and you put on like that
20 pounds and oh man you should see my
credit card bill now
i'll i'll tell you what greg to to yes
and emily's point
uh in new york we thrown a billion
dollars at thrive
nyc to help mental health in the last
five years
and judging by people on the subway that
i'm not looking at
that ask me what i'm looking at the city
is getting crazier every year
it is amazing it is amazing how
the mentally ill and this is i'm not
laughing at this because i've been
talking about this this problem in new
york city and the thrive issue the 800
million dollars
that that they can they know when you're
like it's not safe on the subway they
look right at you and then you go oh god
here it comes
cat you must be just when you see all
these drugstores closing
uh this has to scare you oh yeah my
prescription i gotta go further to get
all mine i have a lot of prescription
medication
[Laughter]
you spread them do you spread them out
over pharmacies oh doctor shopping
yeah so no i don't even know what
they're i don't even know what that
phrase means
i heard about it um yeah look the
democrats had a huge opportunity here
right because the police reform is
something that most americans agree we
need
uh they could have done that instead
they said you know what no more cops
done with cops nobody could survive with
that kind of logic
i had food poisoning a few weeks ago if
i was like that's it no more food
i didn't do that i continued to
occasionally eat after
that happened to me um because so it's
no shock when something that dumb
happens that they're not gonna
continue to survive you know how dare
you compare food poisoning to police
brutality
i had i didn't compare it was an analogy
but you know what you're a racist bigot
oh probably a homophobe oh oh yeah yeah
xenophobe yeah yeah you've ticked all
the boxes tonight i'm afraid i can't
wait to see you cancel tomorrow morning
i can't wait to see me be canceled for
homophobia
because that would be quite hilarious
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else